[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is benny
pack
today we're checking out a brand new
couple
danielle and muhammad muhammad
yes i am
from 90 days fiance this was suggested
by you guys
so it better be good if it isn't i'm
blaming you guys
all right let's check out this couple i
love these
do you know daniel and muhammad yeah are
they good
thumbs up all right might say proofs of
daniel and we have it
he started kidding about me so that's
what what made me uh
more interested about him one of my
biggest concerns
was i had to build up the trust with him
and then
i was worried about the age difference
yeah
i would that it i thought it was
someone's mom first oh god
me it's just a number it's just a number
i didn't expect that someone from
another country
muhammad he's the only sane person on
this show and that's what makes him
funny
why she's 41 but she looks
55 all right
this is early this must be one of the
first couples
he's from ohio okay danielle
yeah it's me my friend angie
is coming over last year we found out we
were going through
sort of the same situation she's married
to a middle eastern man
from egypt i want to know what's so
crazy about him come on this isn't
telling me anything
so i'm gonna be completely honest okay
i'm very very worried that you're um
welcome to florida gang he's got the
shirt scamming my mom
he's scamming the mom jesus
christ the comments
someone need to be honest with her man
listen danielle you're old
unattractive if that weren't enough you
don't have much
too much of a personality either
why would a hot young guy travel across
the ocean to be with an overnight
divorcee with two kids in iowa
you got to have a couple months with
that some tunisian arm candy and he got
to come to the states transaction over
stop chasing after him like
he broke your heart or something damn
if he was truly here for the right
reasons to begin with he wasn't here
just for a green card
then it would still be a little bit of
compassion yeah and there's not
so why are you chasing after him if he's
completely compassionate i have the
courtesy of saying i'm leaving
he just walked up the door i really want
to know what the hell did i do to make
his life so bad
nothing you quit playing the game quit
letting him walk
on you i don't think anybody's gonna
fault the fact that
you know you didn't see the red flags or
didn't want to acknowledge the red flags
because you love the man
i get it it's a tale of distorted
reality
i understand now i mean told me that he
worked at a plastics
company so we're gonna have to go to the
pacific area town where
the factories are is this it
yep this is it oh are they going to find
him
god damn investigators man i don't even
know what to say so what's up
wait he's dating someone else i met
louise online
she was very supportive and uh she's
always like
he met a lot too making me feel good
about stuff and give me
advice he never smiled like that with
danielle geez
i wonder why tlc must be sponsoring
muhammad's visa for entertainment valley
if i'm not with daniel of course i'm
gonna try to be with someone like luisa
because she has a good personality
right personality of course of course
yes personality
the difference it makes all the
difference for you doesn't it muhammad
she's always being there for me whenever
i need her i just
why is it bothering me that he's
charging his phone outdoors you're a
restaurant what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
and you're the only person i can't trust
no you are the only person i can trust
i love you lisa i love you we go to
miami and we live happy forever
and we have chargers in miami lisa
now after i left daniel i'm worried
about my immigration status i don't know
if i can't keep my green card or i'm i'm
gonna lose it
danielle made a lot of promises and she
said uh our life is gonna be great here
all right let's hear it but
it turned out to be all lies i cannot
take it anymore
hey hey how are you doing is that the
dad i recently left and uh i have been
staying with a friend and
okay yeah
it's completely crazy what's going on my
name is tom
um i know mohammed i happen to meet him
at walmart
one day uh we just started talking
walmart bro
good friends since then danny they met
at walmart
and the rest is history we are
completely different
the way that she's treating me it's like
not a husband she's treating me like
more like a son
gee i wonder how that came to be huh
agents just the number h is just a
number she's treating me
like there's some crazy age difference i
don't get it
try to make things better but she never
did so i was asking myself
why do i have to be in that situation
am i going to spend all my life being
uncomfortable with someone
like daniel i gave i mean
that's why you marry someone right to be
with someone all your
life right remember when that's what
marriages meant
[Laughter]
marriages they used to mean something
thank you tlc
came up to like almost everything in my
country
my job my friends my family and
everything
all right i understand that mohammed
took off
because he didn't like uh the mom
and now she find him in miami so what's
going on
big follow hit him all the way to miami
how far is that i gotta find this
oh it's not that far is it ah it's only
22 hour drive that's whatever
it's only a thousand five hundred miles
all right let's see this he went down to
miami
really yeah and he put
a pitcher out there where he's on a boat
with louisa
and her friend wow i'm here
in sandusky trying to find my husband
and he's off in miami on a boat with
another woman
partying it up muhammad always claimed
he was just friends with
louisa but i believe that there's
something more going on with them
she is a detective holy sh
oh my god it finally hit me danielle
looks like peter griffin
bruh come on guys he literally stuck
around for two to three years with a
lazy horrible woman
he aren't that beast it's so weird to
see who
the comments are siding with danielle is
so incredibly possessive
i mean it is it was his her husband i
can
to some extent understand but i just
don't know the full context as well i
don't think that looks like
friends he's still married and how's
that gonna look he knows that his
immigration his visa is on the line
since he knows that you figured out that
he scammed you
i think in the beginning he did love me
but then he started getting attention
from
prettier better looking women
that had more money i think he changed
all right some self-reflection here some
character development
that mohamed had sex with louisa
why would you ask that i'm still
yeah definitely here what the [ __ ] do
you think well let me make it very clear
he's a [ __ ]
[Applause]
let me make it clear did not expect her
to say that in that tone
[Applause]
how did she do that well let me make it
very clear he's a [ __ ]
i mean i don't know how else to say it
let me make it clear
i just think that when she has to say it
out loud
it makes it more real for her and that
makes it much more he's a man [ __ ]
and let me make it clear what a friend
muhammad doesn't do
anything that's not going to benefit
muhammad muhammad doesn't care
who he hurts to get there who he steps
on what lie he has to tell
or where he has to stick his penis he'll
do what he has to do to get what he
wants
stop you can stop him why why would you
do that
just break up with him i know a marriage
is a sacred thing but if you entered it
on these circumstances then i don't
think it was that important to begin
with danielle
all right jesus christ dude let it
[ __ ] go
god damn it but it's my husband yeah
okay he clearly married you for the visa
so we're definitely gonna help each
other out you know i do have friends in
miami
so you know they can help him are they
gonna get married jobs and stuff like
that
let's actually go through the water what
if you walk in this hand you're like
this
because it's really heavy don't laugh at
me
right now i want to be with someone i
want to have
company yeah be okay be okay don't
don't mess with my hair the good thing
is
there is no pressure
and you're also the same age you look
fairly similar
a major upgrade from that ohio board
what the [ __ ] is wrong with the comments
dude
you're so mean he straight up pushed her
over wait what
oh hell yeah sure
and he's not a yeah he did the thing
look at that i'm sorry
no i'm sorry i am so sorry
muhammad and luisa face off no wait why
what happened
okay we said we are not here for arguing
or anything so you don't even
call me or text me or anything anymore
like hey what's up
things is not going well so i'm just
trying to be quiet
so you just like disappear that easy is
that what you do with everybody
[Music]
muhammad's love life could be a whole
tlc season how did you
come there for me you came by your own
will
i didn't make you i didn't put a gun to
your head did i of course you didn't but
you
encouraged me to come here and you said
i have a lot of connections
and i'm gonna help you to find jobs and
all that stuff
what made me come to miami yeah
someone who's like always tell me
something and doesn't happen
it was like the same like danielle
she disrespected me i just left not a
sip why did muhammad stop having sex
with danielle geesh i wonder
all right let's watch when we saw the
scene of you two at the wedding you said
that you could not kiss her
yes okay what have you guys ever kissed
before that
yes you have yeah are you intimate
before that yes you have okay so you've
kind of consummated the relationship yes
was there any intimacy
after the wedding at all after the well
yes
there was but we started facing a
problem
yeah what is what was the problem i
don't want to say like this is very
private
instead of taking care of that problem
she was like fighting with me over it
this is something that
no man in the world can accept that and
then
and then she was crying screaming
in front of her teenagers i want my sex
tonight
if you don't give me my sex tonight i
will i will
i will call the immigration i will get
you deported
he has told people that i smell and i do
eat on
okay this person here she has
some stuff that i don't like i i
complain
you know what i don't even i don't even
want to know then
thank you very much thank you very much
for if you're asking me
like why i'm not having sex with her
then you put it
out there i have to explain it you know
oh my god
you know i thought he would have some
subtlety because he said it's very
private it seemed like he wasn't gonna
say anything
and then he got to a point where she's
even saying i don't want to hear it
anymore
well it's so sad i can't believe it to
get him deported
[Music]
it's been months since i've seen him and
i am starting to move on from him
oh if you want him deported i don't
think that you've moved on
i'm pretty sure i'm going back to
college and i'm looking for
a nicer home for me and my daughters and
i even have a new boyfriend
jesus christ that's an evil giggle
i'm over muhammad but i stalk him all
the time i'm starting to move on
picturing draw instead of throwing it
away
yeah right we're in a long-distance
relationship oh nice
he lives like six hours away
i'm moving on from muhammad but i want
to show him
he can't treat someone like this and
expect to get away i'm moving on yeah
yeah yeah okay all right i said
i'm in miami he disappeared i've been
trying to track him down for a while
and i finally found him he's gonna have
a visitor soon and i'm finally gonna get
some payback
oh god they're all crazy it's a
beautiful thing i love it
and i am damn sure he had sex after we
got married did you want to know the
last time i had sex with my husband
three months after we got married do you
think every guy in this world has sex
with his wife every freaking day
i highly doubt it to happen every day
well from the
from the way is that muhammad's friend
sounds like it so where is he getting
sex from
nobody needs to know your sex life
either but you're freaking
talking about that because you think
muhammad's all innocent
he's getting sex from someone he's
getting
it from somewhere else if he's not
having it with his wife
not necessarily
new england newlyweds are always
touching each other filling each other
making love with each other because
they're in love
i'm showing you evidence you know
all the trips he's been on you're making
assumptions no
tom his actions speak louder
than his words i know your court
hearings this week
go in there prove it to the judge see
what the judge has to say
yeah go yell out there get judged i mean
what kind of
hope were you wanting from me
i think we know who the villain is i
think we're figuring it out
whose side are you on
[Music]
are you on muhammad oh my god she's
drawing the line in the sand
i'm neutral i'm a i've tried to be
friends with both of you guys
you're wasting energy that you could be
using
to give to your daughters oh
he's sitting here saying i don't take
care of my dog i never
i never said you didn't take care of
your daughters i'm saying if you want
to waste your energy is always into them
grabs yeah oh man he goes to my kids
grabs a giant pile of muhammad
never thought i would like tom more than
elderly dead legend
now that he knows how bad my financial
problems are i'm afraid he'll want to
leave to go back to tunisia
oh so wait what now you're worried that
he's gonna wanna
i thought you wanted to deport him
basically a sugar mama with no sugar
jesus you need to explain me everything
so i can anderson are they back together
well you didn't tell me that you have
problems before i come here
or is this during before he left why
because i was scared that you would
you wouldn't want me to go outside i
thought you wouldn't want me
you knew the truth dude it's mean you're
you're lying
it's not about scared or not scared
oh so this is what happened during
everything there
why was this posted so much later family
my friends everything
are we gonna be able to figure all this
out before your visa
yeah like even if i even if i moved to
someone
and they had money and they turned out
to have they'll not have money or
whatever i'm just saying hypothetically
right if i find out they don't have
money that's not as bad as i find out
that they lied about it right
that's the issue here and it seems like
that's what muhammad thinks
that we're not god she sounds such a
fake cried isn't she i'm worried
you have to change a lot of things but
i'm afraid
yeah if we don't figure this out that
you're gonna leave
so now we know his actions were
justified problems
i will never leave because of the
problems or cause we don't have money
i will live only if you keep doing
things by yourself
and don't share it with people
because i have some bad news yeah this
is before the wedding
and i'm more bad news more bad news are
you serious
happy about it what is it
what is it they haven't even gotten
married yet how was the english class
today
it was okay muhammad
and it was okay
today i've been hit with another big
problem what is it
tell me what the issue is can i just let
you read this
i lost my job
oh they let me go
why are you what's the reason
explain me more you did something wrong
no i didn't do nothing wrong so how they
fired someone did
nothing wrong they felt that i'm not
good enough
at the job but you wasn't serious
about jobs that's why you lost it
i can find another one i don't believe
that
what we're gonna do you are the only one
responsible for
the money it feels like watching the
room i love it we lost
everything
she hide things on me just because she's
worrying that i will leave and i feel
seem like
it's impossible to change it i think
that i'm wasting my time mohammed yes
paul dolce is that his lawyer nice to
meet you what a [ __ ]
guy he looks like anything from use what
the [ __ ]
i think if you're a lawyer it looks like
anything from you so it's decided to
find another lawyer
and what brings you in today mohammed i
want to ask about uh
the process of the fiancee visa are you
here on a k1 visa yes
when are you thinking of getting married
today oh wow
oh wow that's why i came
here this morning he came to the day
before perfect
if i get married i want to know how long
time it will take till i have that
i don't know how to say it the green
card now sometimes
it could be a few months or eight months
10 months a year it just depends
but i don't i don't know why it takes so
long time
uh there's a lot of fraud he actually
seems like a good attorney
i actually somebody told me that before
because i don't know
it so now i would be responsible uh
for anything she do it after we get
married
yeah essentially her death are yours
held responsible
[Music]
any other questions for me
don't do it muhammad you make me think
about the getting married now
because it's not easy yeah you should
think
before you get married how about that
because uh she will follow you across
country
and she will find you what a couple it
just
it never ends i love it so much
subscribe
for more tlc videos check out the
playlist
and check out the merch we got face mask
you want one of those
you want to look cool like that yeah
shimmer
and subscribe see you guys tomorrow bro
ah children of nine farts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo's switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
we